When there's a gap between our intention
and our impact, we diminish others and
our communication. My name's Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
>> [music]
>> Today I am super excited to chat with my
friend Liz Wiseman. Liz is a researcher,
executive advisor, and CEO of the
Wiseman Group. Liz has written a number
of best-selling books including
Multipliers: How the Best Leaders Make
Everyone Smarter, Impact Players, and
Rookie Smarts. Liz's work has had a
profound impact on leaders around the
globe.
Welcome, Liz. I am so excited to have
our conversation to take what we talk
about when we walk around that lake and
bring it here so everybody can hear.
Thanks for joining.
>> Well, it's always a pleasure and I love
our talks.
>> Thank you. Should we get started?
>> Let's go.
>> All right. For listeners who don't know
your work, what's the core idea behind
being a multiplier or a diminisher? And
how did you stumble onto these patterns
in the first place?
>> Well, let's start with how I stumbled
onto it. You know, right out of college,
my first job, I joined Oracle and I
found myself
in this sea of brilliant people.
Everyone was so smart, so amazing, and I
noticed as those people got put into
management roles,
a lot of them were really smart, but no
one else got to be smart around them.
>> Uh-huh.
>> [sighs]
>> It was almost this like exclusive
intelligence that they were were quick,
they were sharp, they had great ideas,
but other people held back around them
or other people had to sort of recede to
make room for them and their
intelligence and capability.
I ended up calling these leaders
diminishers.
>> Okay.
>> I also noticed other people who were
equally brilliant. People around them
were smart, capable, sharp, took
ownership, stepped up, had ideas. Like
somehow their intelligence was more of a
tool than a weapon.
And I watched this dynamic for years
fascinated. Like why is it that some
leaders seem to amplify intelligence
while others are sucking the
intelligence and life and creativity and
energy out of a room?
And it wasn't until I left Oracle and
saw this pattern with other leaders that
I decided this deserved like some
academic study.
>> Right, and you dove right into it.
Help us understand what are some of the
behaviors and cues and clues that lead
to being a Diminisher? Many people do it
accidentally. They don't say today I'm
going to go, you know, make sure that
everybody pays attention to me and I
they don't get to say that what they
want to say. What are some of the cues
and clues that we can pay attention to?
>> One of the clues that I pay attention to
is the talk to listen ratio.
You know, we find that diminishers tend
to be know-it-alls. They operate in
directives. They're telling people what
to do, whereas the multiplier leaders
are asking people
>> [snorts]
>> what should we do? What can we do? Like
what do you think is possible?
Diminishers tend to be um
a bit of tyrants. They're creating an
environment that is tense, full of
stress, and we know what happens to
people's ability to think and reason and
solve hard problems when they're
experiencing that kind of stress. Um
whereas multipliers
create an environment that's not tense,
it's intense.
And it's not necessarily a lackadaisical
environment, but it's not like, "Hey,
knock yourself out, do whatever you
want." It's like, "I'm going to give you
space
to think, to take risks, to make
mistakes. I'm going to give you time to
experiment, but in exchange for that, I
expect your best thinking. I expect your
best work." And like I'm going to give
you space, but don't you dare give me
anything other than your best thinking.
>> It sounds to me like some of this and
and I know you and I both know Amy
Edmondson, but psychological safety,
setting up an environment where people
can feel safe but challenged to do their
work is what a multiplier does.
>> Absolutely. And at the core of this is
trust. What's at the core of trust is
psychological safety. And I think what I
found with these multiplier leaders
really gets at the heart of Amy's work.
And one of the things I think if Amy
were here, she would say sometimes her
work is misunderstood in that people
think, "Oh, psychological safety is
like, well, I can be ragged. I could say
anything. Like, ooh, don't infringe on
things that make me stressed." And what
Amy would say is that the best leaders
create that kind of safety, but that
alone isn't enough for people to do
great work. They also create stretch.
>> Right.
>> And I think it's in this combination of
comfort, like I feel comfortable here, I
belong here,
I can be myself here,
but then challenge
of like, okay, now we expect you to do
really great work. Like, it's in this
magic of creating both safety and
stretch that people do great work. And
that's really the environment that great
leaders create.
>> I love this tension and focus on stress
versus stretch and you want to create
the opportunities for stretch, not
necessarily for stress.
It strikes me that tone plays a role
here because I was thinking, okay,
what's something I could look in my own
behavior to make sure I'm multiplying
not diminishing. And asking questions
seems to be a reasonable thing to look
at, but I can ask a question with a tone
that can be very diminishing. I can do
the right action, ask a question, but
the way in which I do it can actually be
seen as diminishing. And I find that
really interesting. Have you looked at
not just the verbal actions, the
messages, but how people deliver those
messages is as helping multiply versus
diminish.
>> We see that the currency of a multiplier
leader is inquiry.
Maybe what's at the heart of that is
curiosity and it's asking people
questions um
>> [clears throat]
>> not to placate them
not to humor them. It's asking because
you want to know what they know. It's
being curious that what you don't know,
that somebody else may know may be more
interesting than what you already know.
>> Right.
>> And which is what draws you into the
head of other people. But we all know a
question can be used as a weapon.
>> Yes.
>> Or it can be used as a tool. You know,
we haven't really studied what that tone
is, but I think it's one that everyone
knows. Like you can tell
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> if someone is weaponizing a question
versus is it an honest question? And I
think maybe the litmus test for yourself
as a leader is why am I asking this? Am
I asking this to show off what I know?
Or to catch someone not knowing?
Or am I asking this because I really
want to know what that person knows, the
insight that they bring?
>> Right. So, a question is a tool to get
inside somebody else's head versus to
put them in a particular position. And I
think that's really helpful for people I
love that advice. Ask yourself why are
you asking the question?
Speaking of questions, if you were to
give advice to a leader, what's one
question that a leader could ask, say at
the end of a one-on-one or
all hands meeting, that could serve as a
multiplier and not a diminisher? What
what might a question sound like?
>> If I had one that you might want to ask
regularly as a leader is
what do you need from me
to be able to do great work?
I think it's easy for people to get into
like here's what I want from my leader.
But like a leader's job is to create the
environment
where people can do great work.
And then
have the tone and the posture of we
expect you to do great work here. I
think asking like what is it that I can
do
that would create the possibility for
you to do your best thinking and your
best work is something that I think a
leader should be asking regularly. I
studied multipower leaders. I can tell
you here's what
on average they do, here's what they
tend to do, but everyone's different.
>> Sure.
>> Everyone brings a different leadership
style. Everyone on your team is a little
different and so I think taking this
posture of what does this person need
from me?
>> Right.
>> I think when we focus on not what people
want from us as their leaders, but what
they need from us, it puts us in the
right posture to enable people to do
great work.
>> This notion of being in service of the
people you lead and trying to enable
them through providing them
support, really important. And And a
question that helps get that across
could be very valuable.
>> I want to um add to that. There was
something that uh my boss at Oracle
said, Phil Wilson. He said something
once that has stuck with me forever. He
said, "Your employees are the customers
of your leadership."
>> Yes.
>> I think it's what allowed me to do this
work was to see that like leadership is
truly in the eyes of the beholder. If
you want to know what good leadership
looks like, you don't ask great leaders
cuz they may or may not know what
they're doing that's effective. You ask
the people who work for them.
>> Yeah.
>> And people need different things from us
at different times.
>> Envisioning leadership as serving
customers, those that report to you, is
a really interesting frame. And I I'm
huge on checking the frames that we use
in our communication and I really like
that one. I'm going to add that to my
stock pile of of frames. Thank you. I
think taking a customer service
perspective on all of our relationships
can make a big difference. You know, if
I see myself as a teacher, my students
are my customers. I I teach them very
differently. I'd approach it very
differently than if hey, they just show
up and I'm here to bestow knowledge on
them.
It really changes that perspective. I
appreciate that.
>> You've also studied and written about
impact players at work. What is an
impact player and what do they do
differently from others?
>> Well, impact players are like in short,
>> Yeah.
>> they're the difference makers at work.
They're the people who are doing
standout
work. And not only are they the people
who are making plays and making plays
consistently, they're people who make
the entire teams
around them better. They raise the level
of play, they raise the aspiration on
the team.
And in short, what we found that the
impact players do differently than
ordinary contributors, like rock solid
performers. What they do differently is
they handle everyday ambiguity
differently.
>> Oh, interesting. Tell me more about
that.
>> Yeah, they handle what have become, I
think, the perennial challenges of the
modern workplace like
messy problems, problems without clear
owners, unclear roles, where you can't
quite figure out who's leading this
effort, unforeseen obstacles, something
very inconvenient beyond your control,
changing targets, where the market's
changing, preferences are changing, the
environment policy is changing.
And then unrelenting demands, where the
workload is increasing faster than the
resources to do the work. If you leave
one organization because of all of this
inconvenience, you're going to find it
somewhere else. And
we find that the impact players
approach that
everyday ambiguity really differently
than other people. When the problems are
messy,
while other people are doing their job,
they're figuring out the job that needs
to get done.
>> Oh, I like that distinction.
>> When roles are unclear, while other
people are waiting for direction,
they're stepping up and taking charge.
You know, they realize you don't have to
be in charge to take charge of a
situation. Um when
unforeseen obstacle dropped in your path
while other people are escalating up
to management, they're moving things
across the finish line. When um targets
are changing and other people are
avoiding change, they're adapting,
adjusting, pivoting.
And when the workload is heavy and hard
while other people are adding to the
burden, they're
they're making work light. Like they're
the kind of people who just make hard
work
easier. And while other people are
seeing threat in all of that ambiguity
and uncertainty, they're the ones that
are finding the opportunity in it. This
is a mess. This is an opportunity for us
to do something different.
>> several things there. So, one is
mindset,
drive
uh as well, and this notion of tolerance
for ambiguity. You know, when Rob Siegel
was here talking about the needs of uh
system leaders, it it really is the
ability to you don't have to thrive in
ambiguity, but be at least be able to to
manage it. You work with lots of
leaders, lots of organizations. If you
were to give one bit of advice that you
would like people, leaders, or just
average employees to stop doing in their
behavior or their communication that
gets in the way of all of these things
you're talking about. Is there one thing
that you would advise people to stop
doing?
>> Okay, this is a little conceptual, but
your intent is translating to other
people.
And I want to go back to this idea about
leaders who have a diminishing effect
versus a multiplying effect. And one of
the There were two things that were
startling in this research. One was that
the diminishing leaders were getting
less than half of people's available
intelligence, their knowledge, their
insights, their creativity. I witnessed
this in the workplace, and I assumed
that these multiplier leaders were
getting more, like I don't know, I think
20% was my hypothesis on this.
It's a 2x difference between what these
multiplier leaders are getting and these
diminishing leaders are getting.
But the thing that was even more
surprising is that most diminishing was
accidental.
It wasn't coming from tyrannical,
narcissistic, bully, the decision
makers, the micromanagers.
A lot of it comes from that, but the
majority is coming from really, really
well-intended leaders who are trying to
be good leaders, trying to do the right
thing, are just brimming with positive
intent. But their impact is different
than their intention. Coming to to talk
with you today made me realize that
there's a really important communication
angle behind this. Intent doesn't
translate to impact, particularly when
it comes to leaders. Like, there's so
many ways we accidentally diminish by
being
like idea fountains, by being always on,
by being rescuers, protectors, rapid
responders, pace setters, and they're
all done with really good intent.
>> Yeah.
>> But the intention alone doesn't get the
right result. Like, let me take one of
those.
>> Yeah.
>> The rescuer. This is when a leader sees
someone struggling,
perhaps in a meeting, and like, you see
someone struggling with a hard problem
or they got asked a difficult question,
and your like great big heart kicks in,
and you want to help that person, and
you think you are sending the message of
"I got you. I care about you. I want you
to be successful. I'm here for you. I've
got your back."
But what's messaged in our behavior when
you step in and rescue someone who's
struggling with a difficult problem
or got asked a difficult question,
what's transmitted in our behavior is a
message that says,
>> "You're not capable."
>> Yeah. I don't think you can do it. I
don't trust you. And trust is really at
the core of what good leadership is.
Like to trust other people and then to
be trusted by them. So I think part of
the art of being a good leader is
understanding that intent alone is not
enough. That you really have to work in
the realm of
how your actions are impacting other
people. Align that intent with with
impact. So what should people stop
doing? Assuming that good intent is
enough.
>> Right.
>> Because it's as diminishing as the
tyrannical bully.
>> One of the things I like so much about
the work you do is not only do you give
specific advice, you help categorize and
help people understand, but you have
data behind it. And there are a lot of
people who do some of the stuff you do
that don't have the data. And it's
amazing to me how diminishing can
actually
impact or not impact the work that
happens.
>> [snorts]
>> As you were going through some of these
accidental diminishing behaviors, I saw
many in myself. I often have lots of
brainstorming and think I'm helping
people. Well, maybe I'm not. Maybe I'm
overwhelming. Maybe I'm overshadowing.
How do we uncover
the well-intended acts that could be
diminishing? Is it through having a
coach? Is it through reflection? How do
we learn that about ourselves? I mean, I
had a couple of epiphanies just
listening to that answer. So not
everybody has access to you in the
moment like this.
What can we do so we can figure that out
so we're not doing it? Because as you
said, it's it's not intent. That's not
the intent. The intent is actually the
opposite.
>> You've listed a bunch of them. One is
sometimes just hearing the names. And
there were a few others like
perfectionist, strategist, um optimist.
Which is one of my accidental diminisher
tendency. Sometimes just hearing that
and hearing how like oh yeah, with the
optimism I'm intending to send the
message that I think we can do this.
But what I'm really overlooking is how
hard this is and the struggle it takes
to get there.
So, sometimes just hearing the names is
enough.
Sometimes it requires a conversation.
Here's what I don't recommend anyone do.
Like sit people down and say, "Hey, am I
a diminisher?" Or even asking, "Am I an
accidental diminisher?" Like here's a
question that you could ask and Matt,
this might be one of the questions that
you could ask over and over again.
>> [clears throat]
>> What am I doing with really good
intentions that might be shutting down
good ideas, good thinking? Like what am
I doing with the best of intentions that
is making it difficult for you to do
your best work?
>> I love that question.
>> People can answer that.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's easy for me to talk with
you about like, "Matt, you're doing this
thing that I know you're trying to help
me, but actually like let me suffer and
figure this out. I will figure it out on
my own, but I appreciate the offer."
It's really hard to give feedback to
your boss on things that seem
a little mal-intent.
>> I love it because the question is framed
from a place of you're trying to help.
And I'm actually reflecting some of the
best best critical feedback I've ever
received was in that vein. It was like,
"You're sharing too many ideas. It's
overwhelming." You know, and that was
really helpful for me. Thank you. Many
things you've said have been really
helpful. I I'm going to take that
question and and leverage it.
We'll be right back to finish our
conversation. But first, a quick word
from one of our sponsors. Their support
allows us to bring you this show free of
charge.
One of my favorite things about this
show is hearing from listeners all over
the world. Communication connects us.
And the more people you can communicate
with, the bigger your world becomes. So
many of you are collaborating
internationally, working across
cultures, or simply trying to connect
more deeply with people around the
world. That's one reason I've been
thinking more and more about language
learning. Babbel focuses on helping you
have real conversations with real
people, not just memorized vocabulary.
Their lessons are designed by more than
200 language experts and built around
practical communication skills you can
actually use in everyday life. And
because the lessons are short and
approachable, it's easy to fit them in a
busy schedule. Just 10 minutes a day can
help you make meaningful progress. If
you've ever thought about learning a new
language, this is the perfect
opportunity to start. Right now, Babel
is offering up to 60% off your
subscription at babel.com/tfts.
And now, back to our conversation.
You know, Liz, I knew this was going to
be great. Before we end, I like to ask
everybody three questions. One I make up
just for you and two I've been asking
everybody for a long, long time. Are you
up for that?
>> Let's do it.
>> I know you're currently doing some
really interesting research as you
prepare to bring it into the world. Is
there anything you can share about your
your current focus that that we can one
maybe get intrigued by, but is there a
nugget or two you can share?
>> Yeah, I am looking at the making of a
great leader.
Which means I'm also looking at the
making of a bad leader. And what I'm
trying to understand is how do our
formative experiences
in the workplace and in life, how does
it shape the way that we lead? How does
it shape the way we show up? And what
are the patterns
that the best leaders have experienced?
And what I can share is that there are
some very distinct windows of influence,
periods in our work life where a little
bit of good leadership goes a long way
and a little bit of bad leadership goes
a really long way as well. Like where we
create these imprints that stay with us
for a long time and lurk in our heads
and tell us
how to operate, how to lead. Um few of
those are um our first job and our first
boss has huge imprinting quality. New
assignments, new terrain, anywhere where
we're like doubting ourselves and we
don't know what we're doing. Mistakes
like victories in defeat, the thrill of
victory and the agony of defeat creates
these really formative kinds of
experiences and then of course
our upbringing.
>> Sure.
>> And one of the things that I'm finding
in this research is that the best
leaders, when we look at this pool of
like people are really great leaders
today,
there's a few things they have in
common. They have a history of
adversity.
>> Huh.
>> Early in life or early in career like
resolved adversity. And they don't all
have a history of great bosses.
Like just having great bosses doesn't
make you a great leader.
>> I love that you're studying the
development of leaders both good and
bad. I can think about my trajectory and
some of those key points along the way.
Now as somebody who used to run learning
and development organizations before I
came back to academia, how valuable
would this be to to understand this? So
as you're bringing on new employees,
increasing your bench strength, to
really understand where those key
inflection [snorts] points are and how
you can help people have a more positive
experience. I think that's wonderful. I
look forward to that work.
Let me ask question number two. Who's a
communicator that you admire and why?
>> I wanted to mention Kim Scott.
>> Yeah. Kim's been on the show and is a
friend.
>> Radical candor. There's something I've
noticed that she does regularly. And it
was a real
I think a real factor in the success she
had at Google and she she mentions it in
her book, is that Kim
presents opposing opinions. Like when
she would and I've have her she's a
friend of mine, I see her do this is
like when she would go and be presenting
a case for we need to increase head
count here or funding here or go this
direction
and she would present it to like Larry
and Sergey, she would always say, "But
let me tell you why we might not want to
do that." And I think it's an amazing
practice. If you want to increase the
impact of your communication, don't just
advocate
for a single position. Like be willing
to talk about the downsides, the
underbelly, the risks of that. I think
it massively increases your impact. So
that's just one example and someone I
admire.
>> I've noticed that too, that she she
definitely brings up the opposing view
and and that that really is very
helpful.
Final question. What are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe?
>> Well, I think good communication starts
with respect.
And not necessarily interpersonal
respect, respect for people's time. I
took a writing course early on in my
career and I remember what it said is
the cost of writing is the cost of
reading.
>> Oh, interesting, yeah.
>> So we often think of communication is
like what does it take to create it?
But the real cost of communication is
what it takes to consume it.
And I think when we start communicating
with respect for people's time and
energy they're going to put into the
receiving of it, I think we do a better
job. Maybe next from there would be
empathy.
To understand that the person or people
with whom you're communicating have had
a different
experience with that issue or topic than
you have, that they've got a different
perspective on it, that maybe your point
of view is not the only point of view in
this situation. I think allows us to
communicate better.
And then clarity, like knowing your
point.
>> Being clear and concise, having empathy,
appreciating others come to your content
differently, very important. I really
like this idea of thinking about the
time and energy that those receiving our
messages have to take. How can we
maximize it for them instead of for us?
So much that you have shared with us
that has really helped us. You truly
were a multiplier today for all of us to
learn and grow and it's lovely to learn
from you in this format versus the
walking around the lake that we
typically do. Thank you so much for
being here, Liz, and I look forward to
your new work.
>> It's a pleasure, Matt.
>> Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast. To learn more about leadership
and being your best at work, please
[music] listen to episode 147 and 212
with Whitney Johnson.
This episode was produced by Catherine
Reed, Ryan Campos, and me, [music] Matt
Abrahams. Our music is from Floyd
Wonder. With thanks to the Podium
podcast company.
Please find us on YouTube and wherever
you get your podcasts. Be sure to
subscribe and rate us. Also, follow us
on LinkedIn, TikTok, and Instagram. And
check out fastersmarter.io for deep dive
videos, English language learning
content, and our newsletter.
Please consider joining our Think Fast,
Talk Smart learning community at
fastersmarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, my AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's fastersmarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community.